[Musique]
le premier miracle c'est sans doute
celui là janvier dernier à brasilia
dilma rousseff devient présidente du
brésil
elle est adoubé par son prédécesseur
luiz iniacio da silva lula quoi dilma
c'était sa dauphine le deuxième étage de
la fusée brésil est sur orbite
l'affirmation de la démocratie le modèle
de capitalisme social que lula a inventé
et qui donne un incroyable souffle à son
pays de 200 millions d'habitants
tout cela va se poursuivre et c'est la
meilleure nouvelle pour un peuple
assoiffé de progrès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sao paulo capitale économique du brésil
l'énergie de new york
le climat des tropiques san paolo le
coeur du système qui donne le tempo à ce
pays grand comme 15 fois la france 21
millions d'habitants ici dans cette
métropole la plus importante d'amérique
latine
tout est grand ici même le nombre de
millionnaires 130000 ils sont la cible
des grandes des kidnappeurs des
narcotrafiquants il se protège derrière
les murs de leur résidence
le business des voitures blindées et
prospère celui des gardes du corps aussi
mais les millionnaires sont décomplexés
décontracté il aime le luxe la fiche
sans trop de gêne persuadé d'être partie
prenante dans le développement du pays
et la redistribution des richesses
[Musique]
le must c'est l'hélico
ça me parle en compte le plus au monde
près de cinq cents contre 4 cents à new
york les héliport coiffe les gratte ciel
comme celui de la ville à daslu temple
de l'hyper fric
les vendeuses sont issus de famille
fortunées les employés vêtus en
soubrette
tout ici est conçu pour que les clientes
se sentent comme à la maison
si c'est là l'autre qu'ici c'est dans
votre costume brésiliennes qu'elles
aient fait tous ici au brésil 100% faire
la manche elle est très protégé vous le
montre on travaille avec des femmes qui
travaillent pour nous plus de 40 ans de
la bri ces deux-là produits brésiliens
et quand même même là le plus le plus
beau des grands magasins à paris-xii n'a
jamais eu ce qu'a soutenu encore
centration de luxe je trouve tous
différents c'est la relation qui lie à
intraveineuse et la cliente
oui parce qu'il ya des vendeuses qui
reste avec les clients et c'est
important parce que nous on entre dans
une département sport aux états unis
même demain à paris on n'a pas une veine
deux rivières qui dit impôt alors ça va
on dit toujours il ya la taille d'une
department store maïla le coeur d'une
toute petite boutique des 70 mètres
carrés occupés puis finalement je crois
que les vendeuses et remerciant ses
connaissent d'or de la boutique se
connaissent pas ce qu'il fait aussi
partie de la même vie que la criante
tout ici est fait pour donner du plaisir
aux clients amis et même le moment de la
douloureuse
le passage à la caisse devient presque
un enchantement honnart les sièges la
cliente en à la veille de la caisse
notre personne en demandant la clientèle
veut prendre un verre de champagne
un verre de jus d'orange telle hausse
elle veut s'asseoir
qu'est ce qu'elle veut elle regarde
encore les choses que la vérité elle
voit tout est lié à un moment final
c'est le monde vous regarde tous un
moment est spécial et pourquoi les
pourquoi les brésiliens finalement on
voit dans l'architecturé en point dans
un endroit quoi ils ont un tel goût du
luxe je crois que ça c'est ça ça vient
de la robe créativité de le préserver l
est de la france mentalité de le brésil
il ya beaucoup des pays de l'amérique du
sud sont pas du tout comme nous ils sont
toujours dépressive et ça parce que ça
passe quelques problèmes de l'épreuve
d'économie ils sont toujours là en temps
de parler de le problème nous sommes les
brésiliens sont complètement différents
de ça le problème ce sont les taxes
si on n'avait pas eu ce problème parce
que 1,5 qui ont appris en avant bon
c'est silence à texaco 2000 euros à
paris on peut ici 6000 euros
non c'est prohibitif voilà ma comme la
femme brésilienne les folles elle veut
avoir 5 l attente paga les voyages et a
lâché 6
on a vu qu'on n'arrive pas cette
problème de la taxe
je suis sûr complètement sûr que le
brésil doit être in de les premiers
marchés de luxembourg
on
la semaine de la mode de sao paulo
la fashion-week appellation contrôlée
par la jet set permet à tous les
branchés fortunés de se retrouver une
fois de plus au programme 40 des filets
un seul ne suffira sur les pas de monica
mendes
[Musique]
vous avez des jardins historiques qui
viennent de france a enchaîné en tout ca
sont toutes les analystes grâce à mal
bien non
the place to be comment vous expliquez
que la fashion week de sao paulo ça a
pris une dimension
international
pose pourquoi rappeler l'activité de
l'effet séguin
on a fait maintenant 15 ans
bachand
et dans sa lancée pour
ça va
[Musique]
et maintenant c'est le moment du
président
les modèles sont de reynaldo lourenço
l'un des stylistes les plus cotés
question ambiance badinage et
exhibitionnisme sanpaolo n'a rien à
envier aux collections parisiennes les
riches brésiliens qui ont des fonds à
placer m investir aussi dans le business
brésilien de la mode lui ce marcus elias
il a fait fortune dans l'agroalimentaire
il pèse plusieurs centaines de millions
de dollars
il adore papillonner parmi les
mannequins et les jeunes beautés assez
souvent au fait mais bon la chirurgie
esthétique fait partie ici de la culture
marcus elias a accès au backstage du
défilé
hilmi a convié je vous présente mon amie
carole à chanter c'est ma prochaine
femmes
non non je suis marié j'ai un fils moi
aussi j'ai trois enfants
c'est juste un très bon ami à moi et
plaisante vous avez aimé le défilé
beaucoup c'est très sophistiquée très
élégant oui très élégant
marcus elias le tycoon doit beaucoup à
lula le syndicaliste l'accession au
pouvoir de nombre de gauche en 2002 a
profité à toutes les classes de la
société
c'est là le deuxième miracle brésilien
cardozo le prédécesseur de lula à la
tête du pays avait accompli les réformes
les plus difficiles lutte contre
l'inflation en réduction des déficits
mais c'est lola camille réellement le
brésil sur une rampe de lancement
il a su rassurer les milieux d'affaires
nationaux les investisseurs
internationaux
et pourtant le compagne héros fidel
castro assister à l'investiture de son
ami lula qui accédaient au pouvoir sous
la bannière du très radical parti des
travailleurs
[Applaudissements]
quand lula a été élue
marcus elias et les chefs d'entreprise
n'était pas rassuré tout le monde
elle était très inquiet de savoir si
lula ne ferai pas de choses folles au
niveau économique et aussi au niveau
politique des produits qu'elle est le
premier signe que lula a donné pour vous
rassurer il a immédiatement fait une
déclaration officielle et envoyer un
message au parlement pour dire je ne
changerais rien je ne toucherai pas à la
stabilité économique
je ne nationaliserait pas les
entreprises et je ne remettrait pas en
cause le droit à la propriété privée
à partir de là tout le monde s'est
détendu et la confiance est revenue
qu'est-ce qui a fait que finalement
c'est sous le régime de lula le pays a
décollé et que notamment les
millionnaires aussi ont fleuri le nom de
ce miracle c'est la redistribution des
revenus notre société avec beaucoup de
mal à résoudre cette situation très
injuste citoyens qui faisait qu'une
grande majorité de la population était
très pauvre
le président lula a réussi à mettre en
place une série de mesures économiques
et sociales qui au bout du compte ont
permis une redistribution des revenus
ordre et progrès la devise est inscrite
sur le drapeau brésilien et des drapeaux
il y en a partout dans ce pays où l'idée
de nation d'appartenance à la même
collectivité demeure très fort direction
le nordeste la région qui s'étend de
bahia jusqu à belém à l'embouchure de
l'amazone y ce territoire immense reste
le plus démunis du pays
mais ça va mieux comme ici à rai chabat
l'une des mesures phare des deux
gouvernement lula
la bolsa familia a permis à des millions
de pauvres de sortir de l'indigence
absolu et c'est là le troisième miracle
brésilien
dans cette ville de 17000 habitants deux
tiers des familles touchent la bolsa
familia
un exemple très concret de ce que notre
millionnaire tout à l'heure marcus elias
appelé la redistribution des revenus
marie lurdes trois enfants elle
bénéficie de la môle saint la retire
chaque mois au bureau de la loterie
nationale
mais le hasard n'a rien à voir là dedans
c'est le résultat d'une politique
elle reçoit 65 euros c'est peu et c'est
énorme lorsque le revenu mensuel ne
dépasse pas 2 165 euros
je suis très heureuse avec son mari
lurdes peut équiper ses enfants pour la
rentrée des classes mais elles restent
encore timides devant les magasins
qu'elle n'a pas l'habitude de fréquenter
nous écoute
non je regarde juste les tripes
en contrepartie de la bolsa les enfants
doivent d'abord être scolarisés maman je
vais tout ça je veux tout ça toi la
bolsa c'est simple ça marche
elle profite à 12 millions de foyers 50
millions de personnes le quart de la
population du pays
je prends pas le sac à dos ça coûte trop
cher c'est vrai qu'avec la bolsa familia
je vends plus car les trois c'est cher
avec le phare un tueur mais il faut
aussi les sandales des habits pour aller
à l'école
[Musique]
le futur sera meilleur même les
brésiliens les plus modestes
en foi en leur avenir qu'elle a grandi
qu'elle peut être chanteuse mais il faut
d'étudiants et lui il est chauffeur la
petite a peut être danseuse de quoi je
sais pas elle est encore un peu tôt pour
le savoir
j'espère beaucoup de choses j'ai
vraiment confiance dans l'avenir
j'espère que la bolsa familia ne
s'arrêtera jamais conséquemment une
bataille à dole jmv bill une star du rap
brésilien dans ce clip il incite les
gens à toucher la bolsa sur bois soie
avait sa famille
[Musique]
la bolsa pour la voir il faut la vouloir
la mériter et respecter quelques
engagements la scolarisation des enfants
mais aussi leurs vaccinations au brésil
le secteur de la santé est malade à
l'agonie la bolsa permet un meilleur
accès aux soins
la fréquence des hépatites et des
pneumonies a beaucoup diminué
aujourd'hui c'est devenu très rare avant
on avait des cas de méningite et
maintenant on en voit plus maria lurdes
prend la bolsa très au sérieux
en cas d'absentéisme répété à l'école la
location peut être supprimées de zèle
dont le père coupeurs de canne à sucre
ils triment
il croit lui aussi à un avenir meilleur
pour ses enfants
je ne sais pas lire et j'en ai honte
pour mes parents c'était difficile je
n'ai pas pu étudier
je dis à mes enfants qu'il faut étudier
car c'est meilleur pour eux et pour moi
aussi la bolsa c'est une aide par
exemple pour acheter un cahier mais on
peut pas tout acheter avec ça bon la
bolsa ce n'est qu'un début
un petit coup de pouce pour quelques
habits
un frigo un peu moins vides mais ce
n'est plus la misère extrême
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rio la magnifique les plages de
copacabana et d'ipanema et les favelas
il y en a plus de 1000 qui viennent
s'échouer au coeur de la cité mais même
dans ces bidonvilles ça commence à
bouger la bolsa familia encore mais
aussi l'augmentation du smic
de plus de 74 % en dix ans
marcelo neri un économiste renommé il
vit dans un quartier aisé de rio au
sommet de sa colline luxueuse
confortable bien gardé il y à une favela
neri jubile en me conduisant la favela
n'est plus une zone de non droit comment
s'appelle cette favela morro de ska
britos la colline des chefs elle a été
nettoyée des narcos mais aujourd'hui on
peut il descendre sans risque oui on
peut on peut laisser très récent ça fait
à peine un an
là vous pouvez voir les progrès ont
construit mais regarde là c'est vraiment
une merveille
c'est quoi le quartier là bas c'est
copacabana et ça c'est la favela en face
oui de la favela
au milieu les immeubles de la classe
moyenne après ces deux mètres carrés le
plus cher du brésil et on voit bien la
division des classes on a tous le
contraste entre richesse et pauvreté
côte à côte en les gens que je vois ici
sont quand même plutôt noir oui les
pauvres sont plutôt noirs et les blancs
et bien ne sont pas pauvres
pourquoi c'est dû à l'histoire mais les
choses sont en train de changer
le revenu des noirs a augmenté trois
fois plus que celui des blancs ces dix
dernières années
si on compare avec les autres pays
émergents comme l'inde la chine et même
la russie les inégalités augmentent au
brésil elle diminue c'est à dire que le
revenu des noirs croît plus vite que
celui des blancs ils augmentent plus
vite dans les favelas ce que dans les
quartiers riches
tous les pauvres au brésil vise une
croissance à la chinoise alors que le
reste des gens connaît une croissance
moins rapide ce qui est très bien car
cela permet de réduire les inégalités et
la pauvreté
la violence demeure encore c'est une
tâche un couac un poison pour l'image du
pays
la plupart des favelas reste encore sous
le joug des trafiquants de drogue
mais ça change et c'est là le quatrième
miracle brésilien
les autorités ont décidé de nettoyer une
à une les favelas ça prendra du temps
il s'agit chaque fois de véritable
opération de guerre bon gros dos macacos
la colline des singes une favela de 27
mille habitants au nord de rio
les u pp la police de proximité s'est
installée voici trois mois après que les
troupes d'élite et nettoyer 220
policiers se relaient pour assurer la
sécurité des habitants
la colline des macaques était tenu par
les amis des amis l'un des gangs les
plus redoutables de rio l'opération des
unités d'élite contre les narcos s'est
déroulée en octobre 2009
ça c'est une des entrées de la favela
avant ici c'était impossible d'entrer
comme ça parce que les trafiquants nous
guetter dès qu'on arrivait ils nous
tiraient dessus c'était impossible
d'entrer et maintenant vous voyez on a
un véhicule et 2e en faction ici en
permanence ça s'est passé quand c'était
l'an dernier avant qu'on libère la
favela
la femme a été contrôlée par un groupe
fortement armé on ne pouvait pas rentrer
seuls les forces spéciales ont réussi il
a fallu 200 ou 300 hommes pour y arriver
voici l'opération pacification de la
favela
ouais
et moi
douze tués et un hélico de l'armée a
battu
[Musique]
3 tonne et demie de cocaïne de crack et
plusieurs dizaines d'armes de guerre
saisis
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la paix semble revenue plus
bp a installé ses postes en bas et ici
en haut de la colline opération
séduction
oui
c'est le point le plus haut de la favela
c'est là qu'ils exécutaient leurs rivaux
les trafiquants jeu mais en foot sur ce
terrain c'est là où ils se rencontraient
les trafiquants est là devant cette
cabane il y avait toujours un type avec
une arme qui faisait le guet
[Musique]
tous
on a vu vous êtes toujours un peu sur
vos gardes
donc il ya encore du danger important
parce que il peut toujours se passer
quelque chose on doit être prêts à
réagir tout le temps non premier mandat
qui ne peut pas se promener ici comme si
rien ne s'était passé
on sait comment c'était ici avant donc
on prend nos précautions les
narcotrafiquants quand ils sont partis
où ils sont allés dans la zone ouest
dans des secteurs pas encore libéré les
secteurs plus vulnérables et donc le
problème est déplacé mais il n'est pas
réglé en tout cas dans le coin ici il
est résolu elle est vraiment résolu
réseau et puis l'étau se resserre
bientôt ils ne sauront plus où aller
c'est sa favela après favelas
tu peux
[Musique]
pour adolfo mendel le président de
l'association des résidents
le temps des assassinats c'est le passé
et ce genre de sanctuaire est un vestige
et bien sûr c'est pour rendre hommage au
sang des narcotrafiquants ce sont des
jeunes qui sont morts dans des
fusillades dans des échanges de tirs
avec la police ou entre la fille aussi
et maintenant c'est terminé
ils sont tous morts comme ça même latine
s'est complètement terminée plus un seul
coup de feu
depuis l'installation de l'ump des
habitants qui était parti pour ne pas
vivre soumis aux trafiquants commence à
revenir les services publics s'installe
comme le camion internet envoyé par la
mairie pour que les jeunes s'initient à
l'ordinateur
succès garanti pour adolfo aussi c'est
le temps du changement
maintenant on se réunit régulièrement
avec les pouvoirs publics pour voir ce
qu'on peut faire
par exemple là on vient d'installer ce
système d' alerte pour la population
aujourd'hui même oui on viens de
l'installer aujourd'hui même quand il
pleuvra trop fort c'est qu'il y aura un
risque de glissement de terrain
je me signale sonnera pour dire aux gens
de se mettre à l'abri
or de la favela avant que la favela ne
soit pas s'y fier c'était possible ça
avant non impossible
non
c'est surtout les femmes qui les
premières ont ressenti les effets de la
pacification
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes mieux maintenant avant oui ç'a
changé en bien
les enfants peuvent jouer il ne risque
pas une balle perdue dans une fusillade
avec la police et les femmes peuvent
sortir faire les courses et laisser les
enfants à la maison
il y a plus de danger c'est beaucoup
mieux qu'avant
est ce que maintenant lorsqu'un conflit
avec les voisins c'est plus facile
qu'avant oui parce que maintenant s'il
ya un problème là où j'habite
je vais chercher la police je vais
chercher la police et voilà c'est réglé
[Rires]
moi je dis à mon mari que s'il me menace
j'appelle la police et ça lui fait peur
tous les mecs en ont peur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur les plages de rio en pratique toutes
les mixités
ici ceux qui se livrent ce dimanche au
sport national baignade des plages
appartiennent surtout à la classe
moyenne
la classe montante du brésil
[Musique]
en huit ans 31 millions de personnes ont
rejoint la classe c comme on la désigne
ici c'est le cinquième miracle brésilien
la classe moyenne représente déjà la
moitié de la population
elle est le moteur du développement
économique et elle en profite
[Musique]
pour notre économiste marcelo neri ce
n'est qu'un début
faire partie de la nouvelle classe
moyenne dans ce pays c'est croire qu un
meilleur futur nous attend les
brésiliens sont plutôt convaincu de vous
donner un exemple bien que l'an passé en
2010 la croissance a permis la création
de 2,2 millions d'emplois stables ça
signifie que les entrepreneurs
investissent ils ont confiance dans
l'avenir
ils créent des emplois parce que la
croissance est saine dans les quatre à
cinq années à venir entre 28 et 33
millions de personnes supplémentaires
devraient rejoindre la nouvelle classe
moyenne
c'est la moitié de la population de la
france direction sous la cape à l'ouest
de rio un quartier résidentiel très
prisé par la classe moyenne
piscine espace vert absence de favelas
principale attraction cet hypermarché
d'une chaîne française
ce genre de centre commercial est
devenue le lieu favori de la classe c
[Musique]
monica est caissière dans cet
hypermarché un boulot à plein temps qui
lui a permis de sortir de la précarité
[Musique]
après son travail monica troque son
uniforme de caissière pour sa tenue de
nouvelles consommatrices
ma vie et mon régime alimentaire se sont
beaucoup améliorées mon mari et moi on
aime bien manger par exemple le rôti de
boeuf
j'en fais tous les dimanches j'adore
aussi la morue et j'aime pouvoir
m'acheter une bonne huile d'olive tout
ça aujourd'hui je peux me le payer
j'en ai à la maison avant non parce que
mon mari et moi on n'avait pas d'emploi
on devait se partager un beignet au
déjeuner à se partager un baigneur parce
que vraiment on n'avait pas un rond mais
ça c'est le passé de la pénurie monica
et son mari ont fait table rase
[Applaudissements]
complet
ça je l'aï acheté mais j'aimerais bien
ont changé on a acheté en inox
c'est plus à la mode c'est beaucoup plus
beau but
à la caisse monica paie comptant quand
elle peut avec sa carte de crédit
rebbie le crédit débit au brésil on peut
tous payés à crédit souvent sans frais
pour les achats courants monica essaie
de faire attention
mehal a du mal à résister ici tu peux
payer à crédit à partir d'un euro 50
c'est vrai il y en a beaucoup qui paie a
créé diallo caisse les gens chez
tellement qu'ils disent qu'ils ont
explosé leur plafond de crédit qu'ils
n'ont plus d'argent
le crédit c'est le ressort de la
consommation au brésil l'un des outils
de la croissance chez elle dans cette
arrière-cour où elle vit avec son mari
joël c'est la caverne d'ali baba
elle occupe pourtant un logement de
fortune
trois petites pièces vétustes louées à
sa belle mère avec son mari
propriétaires et chauffeurs de taxis
collectifs
il gagne un peu plus de 2000 euros par
mois qui leur brûlent les doigts
ça je les payais en cinq fois et celui
là je les payais content ça aussi et ça
aussi ça je les payais en cinq fois avec
ma car l'ordinateur je les payais en 10
x et le téléphone en cinq fois c'est ça
ça je les payais anti foie et sa content
et ça j'en ai acheté de l'appareil photo
j'en ai acheté avec pour moi et un pour
ma fille qui essaie gober j'ai acheté en
cinq fois avec ma carte
[Musique]
pour les gens comme moi et tous ceux qui
essayent de s'en sortir
ils savent maintenant qu'ils peuvent y
arriver il prospère ce n'est pas que moi
mais tous ceux qui mouillent leur
chemise du sud
aujourd'hui le pays leur donne la
possibilité de s'épanouir et pour nous
le prouver
monica et joël nous amène en famille et
en voiture voir leurs derniers achats
la berline elle
ils l'ont acheté il ya deux ans avec un
crédit de 60 mensualités
[Musique]
leur rêve avoir un appartement à eux
ils viennent de le réaliser
[Musique]
regarde joël ça va être super league et
même une aire de jeux wii une heure de
jeu il n'y a pas encore grand monde
oui tout a été vendu mais les gens ne
sont pas encore là dans l'appartement un
trois pièces de 50 m² est encore en
travaux
il a coûté 42 mille euros l'état
providence leur donne une aide de 10000
euros pour l'acquisition
le reste est financé grâce à un crédit
sur 25 ans c'est un rêve qui se réalise
même une victoire avoir notre propre
maison il ya longtemps qu'on attendait
ça et finalement on y est taché gains
d'ici 3 ou 4 mois on pourra vivre ici
tout ça est la situation du brésil
on peut dire que c'est grâce à lula
c'est aussi ce qu'on attend d'un nouveau
gouvernement que ce soit encore mieux
que dilma fasse encore plus que dollars
c'est notre espoir
comment ne pas être séduit depuis ce
balcon d'un hôtel de rio
c'est si beau ce pays a le bon rythme sa
population est jeune
partout j'ai ressenti cette volonté
d'avancer et surtout la certitude d'y
parvenir
quand on vient d'un pays où règne le
pessimisme
c'est une cure d'espérance dieu est
brésilien c'est la boutade préféré des
cariocas
[Musique]
le brésil est riche si riche
l'ex porte bien plus qu'ils importent
métaux précieux minerai pétrole ici à
recife encore un autre miracle agricoles
et énergétiques l'état note plus de la
moitié des voitures au brésil route avec
ce combustible fabriqué localement à
partir de la canne à sucre
c'est plus écolo moins cher que le super
mais ont fait moins de kilomètres avec
un plein aussi les moteur flex marshall
et sans soin l'éthanol mélanger ou pas
chacun fait ses comptes et choisit en 30
ans le brésil est devenu un géant du
pétrole vert il en est le premier
exportateur 450 usines produisent un
tiers de l'éthanol mondiale mais tout
cela a un prix
c'est le revers de la médaille du
miracle économique
odette gratchev est le fondateur du
forum social mondial ancien conseiller
ex-amie de lula il a introduit dans les
milieux d'affaires mais il regrette la
mollesse de lula face aux puissances
d'argent
est-ce que vous pensez que finalement il
a été impressionné par le monde de
l'entreprise par le grand capital par
les financiers personne ne devient le
président du brésil sans le soutien des
grandes entreprises
c'est fondamental pour devenir président
du brésil
je crois que lula aurait dû avancer
davantage
il aurait pu affronter quelques conflits
avec les grandes entreprises pour faire
avancer l'agenda social du pays et aussi
l'agenda environnementale
l'agenda démocratique l'agenda de toutes
les réformes qu'il n'a pas fait
et pour cela il fallait affronter des
résistances prendre le risque de les
favoriser les plus riches
les puissances économiques et ça il ne
l'a pas fait un signal très négatif dans
la gestion de lula a été le départ de la
ministre marina silva du ministère de
l'environnement
c'est quelqu'un de très respecté au
brésil et dans le monde comme défenseur
du développement durable et elle s'est
opposée au type de développement adoptée
par le brésil c'est à dire une grande
importance donnée à l'agro-industrie au
détriment de la protection des forêts
entre autres en gros ce modèle de
développement ne prenaient pas en compte
la question environnementale et le
développement durable dans le nordeste
comme dans toutes les régions agricoles
du brésil
la monoculture fait loi en amazonie
c'est le soja qui avance dans la forêt
ici c'est de la canne à sucre à perte de
vue
ce modèle agro-industriel base est de
surcroît sur l'utilisation d'engrais de
pesticides des vastes l'environnement le
père tiago et écossais arrivé au brésil
voilà quarante ans il se bat pour les
droits des petits paysans et des
travailleurs de la canne pour lui tout
miser sur l'éthanol est une aberration
97 % de la forêt atlantique à twente a
été détruite par laquelle la suave le
brésil sacrifie sa souveraineté
alimentaire on a déjà commencé à
importer des produits de base de
l'alimentation paysanne des haricots et
le rire
ils préfèrent remplir les réservoirs
plutôt que les ventres et pour étendre
leurs plantations les grands
propriétaires des loges les petits
paysans
ici il ya dix ans cinquante familles ont
été expulsées le père tiago nous amène à
la rencontre d'une résistante victimes
des grands propriétaires
ici il y avait d'autres maisons montre
nous elle était bien c'est un morceau du
sol d'une des maisons
ils ont été expulsés de force on ne s'y
attendait pas la police le juge des gens
de la plantation sont arrivés ils ont
tout emmené tout ce qu'il y avait dans
les maisons qu'ils l'ont mis dans des
camions ils peuvent faire ce qu'ils
veulent me tuer je mentirai pas les gens
sont partis parce qu'ils ont eu peur
quand les vigiles sont arrivés ils ont
brutalisé tout le monde même les enfants
tiens regarde il ya les vigiles qui nous
surveillent ils sont toujours là pour
l'instant
maria francisca a obtenu le droit de
rester sur ce bout de terrain où ses
parents vivent et depuis 60 ans mais la
compagnie sucrière continue de la
harceler
si je viens en permanence sous la menace
quand vous êtes arrivé
les vigiles
sont venues dès que quelqu'un grand
visite ils sont là avec leurs armes
difficile de dire combien de temps maria
francisca arrivera à résister dans cette
région 15 mille familles ont déjà été
expulsés
[Musique]
les géants de la canne à sucre sont très
puissants trop mais il emploie près d'un
millions de brésiliens le droit des
travailleurs même s'il a progressé sous
la présidence lula est ici bafouée
travail de forçat 5 à 6 tonnes à couper
chaque jour payer 8on narciso est venue
donner un voisin pour trouver du travail
et nourrir ses quatre enfants
depuis que je suis enfant j'ai toujours
travaillé dans la can je la coupe en jeu
là là je la nettoie et je la bois mais
[Applaudissements]
aucun travail n'est bon mais celui là
c'est vraiment le pire ça existe trop
d'efforts c'est trop fatiguant on est
obligé de se réveiller à 3 heures du
matin et quand on peut enfin aller se
coucher c'est la nuit et il est 22
heures
je crois que je vais me battre toujours
pour que mes enfants n'est pas à faire
le même travail
c'est le dernier boulot qu'un homme
devrait avoir à faire ces coupeurs on
les appelle les boys à fria
littéralement les mange froid
chaque année plusieurs dizaines
d'ouvriers meurt d'épuisement dans les
plantations
selon les ong brésilienne quarante mille
personnes seraient victimes de travail
forcé dans la can
ce matin là les ouvriers sont en colère
et chose rare en grève la direction de
l'usiné a stoppé la récole à cause des
intempéries et leur a demandé de
nettoyer la cale c'est encore plus dur
est moins payé le père tiago est venu
soutenir les grévistes
mon conseil les amis c'est de continuer
à vous battre comme ça
soyez fair ghana qui disent qu'il faut
collaborer avec l' usine collaborer mon
cul les travailleurs doivent d'abord
exiger leurs droits et être traité avec
dignité
pierre de dieu terre des frères c'est ça
les amis via le matin pour coûter 300 m²
et on nous en demande deux ou trois pas
plus et à la fin de la journée on est
mort de fatigue
le dirigeant du syndicat local a déjà
subi plusieurs tentatives d'assassinât
les patrons le considère comme un
agitateur dangereux tiens regarde ces
votes
elles sont toutes courir que ceux qui
ont les bottes les plus abîmées se met
devant ce qu'on les montrer aux gens
musique quand ils viendront
ce jour là finalement les représentants
de lusine vont négocier un accord mais
l'entreprise n'en est pas à son premier
abus l'an dernier elle a été condamnée à
cent quarante mille euros d'amendé pour
avoir exploité et sous payé 250
travailleurs dont 25 adolescents
ce qui ne l'a pas empêché de recommencer
au brésil si le droit des travailleurs
existe il peine encore à se faire
respecter
un chantier de plus pour dilma rousseff
la nouvelle présidente est elle en a des
choses à accomplir éradiquer la
corruption protéger l'environnement
réformer le système fiscal et politiques
mettre sur les rails
l'éducation et la santé moins
charismatique que lula elle semble mieux
armé moins indulgente aussi avec les
corrompus je crois enfin je souhaite que
le gouvernement dise main et le courage
d'affronter les réalités et j'espère
qu'elle y arrivera
un des grands problèmes brésilien c'est
l'efficacité de l'état
il paraît qu'elle est très intéressée
par la question de la bonne gouvernance
et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle car si le
brésil à un niveau d'imposition
comparable à celui de la france par
exemple nous avons des services publics
qui sont au niveau de ceux des pays
africains du coup tous ceux qui ont un
peu d'argent au brésil n'utilisent pas
les services publics
ils sont pour les pauvres et les pauvres
n'ont pas de poids politique parce qu'il
ne finance pas les campagnes électorales
voilà pourquoi les services publics sont
si mauvais kayak est selon vous la la
mesure qu'il conviendrait de prendre le
plus rapidement possible au brésil ce
serait de faire de l'éducation
l'objectif prioritaire de la société
brésilienne
[Musique]
l'éducation publique la grande lacune du
système brésilien
un homme essaie de dribbler tous les
obstacles qui freinent la scolarisation
[Musique]
il veut marquer des buts ailleurs que
sur un terrain de foot
il s'appelle rail immense joueur de foot
etc star du psg
il met sa notoriété à profit pour lutter
contre l'analphabétisme et la médiocrité
de l'enseignement public avec leonardo
son ancien coéquipier ils ont créé gol
de letra traduction un but pour
l'éducation une fondation pour
promouvoir l'enseignement des jeunes
dans les quartiers pauvres 25 % des
brésiliens seulement seraient totalement
alphabétisés des chiffres indigne de la
huitième puissance mondiale
[Musique]
au brésil on ne prononce pareils il est
totalement investi dans sa fondation il
me l'a fait visiter avec passion rail
n'a jamais été client dépasse people à
l'époque de sa gloire footballistiques
il était différent au sérieux est
intéressé par la politique
et depuis la création de sa fondation
mille deux cents enfants ont bénéficié
des activités de gol de letra ici à san
paolo
mais aussi à rio racontez nous un peu
votre formation
si c'est en fait c'est un grand centre
culturel sportif éducatif
il ya un théâtre musique danse à roissy
yat il était lié à la bibliothèque
itunes culture dans l'informatique ainsi
donc ils ont ils ont quatre au brésil
l'école c'est dès mi journée ils ont
quatre heures et demie en plus en plus
d'écoles en plus de l'école en ce moment
il ya peu de gens parce qu'on est en
vacances aux langues vacances il a cédé
les offres des jeunes c'est des jeunes
cons
ce qu'ils ont passé la plupart sont
passés pour les stages plus petit il a
plaidé viennent des moniteurs c'est bien
déjà dans cette génération où les plus
jeunes ceux qui ont commencé les
premiers peuvent déjà à prendre à ceux
qui viennent maintenant exactement pour
railler il s'agit bien plus que
d'apprendre à lire ou à écrire
il veut que la fondation change le
destin des enfants comme le football a
changé le sien et là c'était une
maquette chef ou des enfants saison avec
quelques changements qu'ils veulent déjà
fais un peu plus d'un an montrent en
réalité et la sensation cette phrase
c'est très symbolique s'est agi non
qu'elles soient commises jean fricou
12h25
ça vient d'où on veut pas seulement à
manger on veut à manger diverses et aph
il doit enfin on veut à manger en veut
les divertissements et on veut dollar
c'est ça
la ville le plus la plus riche
l'amérique latine on est
dans la banlieue on a pas il ya des
quartiers encore plus pauvres qui ici et
tu vas aller il ya des enfants les douze
trésor qui sont à l'école ils sont ils
savent pas lire et écrire
c'est inacceptable on peut imaginer dans
un état plus pauvres dans une ville plus
peuvent régulièrement le brésil et
lycées blaise est pas une ville de
fermont ne sont pas acquises tu peux
imaginer tout ce qu'on doit encore faire
pour votre région
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire le but
final s'est attiré l'attention qui si
jamais en deux heures pour se donner une
bonne éducation bonnes opportunités des
formations aux gens ils vont se
développer il c'est eux qui vont faire
tous les changements qu'il faut vous
pays commençait pour par le quartier la
famille le quartier l'école et tout ça
ça c'est un peu le l'esprit et vous
pensez savoir il n'y a pas de démocratie
il n'y a pas d'indication technicalité
ça n'existe pas nous voici donc une
façon d'une autre continue à être un
pays
une minorité commander cliquez et c'est
la plus grosse et je suis pour ma au
pays
on l'aura compris il reste beaucoup à
faire pour que le brésil accède pouces
cercle très fermé des pays développés en
tout cas l'énergie est là l'envié
l'argent aux signes et plus sur tout
partout
cet optimisme sans faille et après tout
n'est ce pas là l'essentiel
[Musique]
je pense que le brésil est à la croisée
des chemins qui peut devenir un pays
développé dans tous les sens du terme
c'est possible il a cette opportunité et
s'il peut aussi laisser passer cette
chance
ça va se décider dans les cinq ou dix
prochaines années si je dirais que nous
avons encore beaucoup de choses à faire
nous n'y sommes pas encore mais nous ne
sommes pas loin c'est ce que je pense
mais ce qu'il ya de bien avec le brésil
et qui est très différent des autres
pays c'est que nous sommes ouverts
d'esprit et de coeur mode et et surtout
nous les brésiliens nous voulons
toujours aller de l'avant mais à dix
dream nous avons en nous cet espoir que
demain sera meilleur qu'aujourd'hui tous
des noms c'est ça la clé l'équipe
et puis que chez ge est un être un peu
plus considère franchi politique je rêve
de deux nouveaux systèmes
je sois génomique adapté au monde actuel
les je crois que le brésil peut être un
défi un grand grand grand défi pour le
pays
[Musique]
est ce que on va pouvoir parler dans les
années qui viennent d'un modèle
brésilien je crois que le brésil n'est
pas un modèle pur modèles hybrides c'est
ce que j'appellerais un capitalisme
social qui allie les avantages des deux
nous avons en même temps un marché fort
et un gouvernement fort c'est ça le
nouveau brésil et je crois que c'est un
bon modèle pour les pays d'amérique du
sud qui sont trop orientée vers le
marché bien trop étatisée brésil et dans
cette voie du milieu
de tout et tout
difficile de ne pas souhaiter bonne
chance au brésil
[Musique]